we have some horrifying new revelations
out of rural New Mexico and that
horrible case there that the media not
showing you according to the most recent
evidence the Hodge family has been using
their compound as a terrorist training
camp for the 11 children they were
holding agents found these handwritten
letters titled phases of a terrorist
attack which detail the steps to a
successful suicide attack in the name of
Allah yes in the United States of
America despite all that a judge in New
Mexico today decided to release three of
the five defendants ruling that
authorities violated the state's 10-day
rule how do you botch that Andy
McCarthy's back with us on thoughts and
I'm so glad you stayed Andy because this
also is an interesting connection to the
case
that you worked on for the ninety three
World Trade Center bombing where to get
to that in a moment but explain how we
could get to this place where three of
the five defendants are released well
Laura they it they made these arrests a
couple of weeks ago and I guess they've
been investigating since and they gotten
to the point where they either have to
charge them in an indictment or go
through what they call a probable cause
or a preliminary hearing and what I
sense happened was they decided that two
of these characters were the ringleaders
and they appear to have ratcheted up the
charges on the two of them and then
decided perhaps that they couldn't make
the case on the other three so they
didn't go forward on those that doesn't
mean that they can't at some future time
yeah indict them but that seems unlikely
to me well and are they I guess it
doesn't matter if they're a flight risk
because they're not charged with
anything but that that's the concern
obviously it was late right right they
had already been sprung on bail to begin
with which was I think in some ways more
outrageous than what happened today
because if if what happened today is
just because they didn't have enough
evidence on these three to go forward
that's one thing but letting any of them
out I think is insane how can you gonna
charge now it's the whole thing drives
it's this whole case was so hideous what
was done to those children one dead but
auntie explain your connection got him
in a minute left to this case in the 93
World Trade Center bombing Laura the
father of the ringleader runs a fairly
notorious mosque in Brooklyn
his name is also Suraj will Hajj and
that mosque hosted the blind Sheikh who
I prosecuted in the early 1990s in
connection with the World Trade Center
bombing and a plot to bomb New York City
Landmarks he actually appeared that is
the elder Suraj will Hajj as a character
witness for the defendants in the trial
so we're seeing you know a guy who has
got meshed in this ideology back when
and here you have the results of it yeah
and you know we're welcoming this into
the United States apparently and then
releasing people back into the system I
don't have a good feeling about this at
all Andy McCarthy thank you so much for
your insights as always so appreciated